[Musique]
et pour en parler
nos invités pierre martinet fondateur de
wind corp security defence et ex agent
de la dgse et bam c'est un billet si ces
parlementaires maliens membres du
conseil de transition à bamako bonsoir
messieurs merci de répondre à nos
questions nicolas lerner le directeur de
la dgs y est donc direction générale de
la sécurité intérieure a dit dans le jdd
dimanche je cite la menace terroriste
reste très élevé pierre martinet à quel
degré violence terroriste islamiste est
toujours élevé depuis de nombreuses
années depuis que on va dire depuis les
années 2000 depuis qu on peut déterminer
une date où ça a pris vraiment de
l'ampleur avec l'attentât du 11
septembre qui a déclenché par mal
d'opérations occidental dans le monde
dans le monde pour éliminer les groupes
l'idée des groupes de terroristes
islamistes notamment al qaïda qui était
à l'époque le fer de lance de cette de
cette coalition islamistes qui
aujourd'hui a pris une ampleur
phénoménale et là il ya considérablement
grossi et a tenté d'instaurer des
califat islamiste en afghanistan en irak
en syrie et au mali ça n'a pas
fonctionné mais quinze vingt ans après
je pense qu'on est reparti pour avoir la
même menace que dans les années 2000
bam c'est un banshee cdd khalifa au mali
comme vient de le dire
pierre martinet votre réaction oui
effectivement comme monotonie qui te
revient de le dire il ya une nébuleuse
qui est mise en route depuis le 11
septembre
suite aux attentats les équipements -
livre m'a notamment
c'est un groupe qui peuvent s'apparenter
à un califat encore si l'effectif que ça
c'est quand même un pays où il ya une
certaine diversité que nous connaissons
en contre j'ai en moi qui qui qui fait
quoi quand et vous je repars légalement
de nicolas lerner un pierre martinet
donc le patron de la dgse puisqu'il
allie également la menace d'une attaque
projeté est considérablement diminué
depuis 2015
ça semble un petit peu paradoxal par
rapport au fait que la menace terroriste
soit toujours présente ça veut dire quoi
exactement est ce qu'un paradoxe non ils
prêtent paradoxe c'était une évolution
des la lutte contre ces groupes
constitués en fait il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs périodes on va dire dans les
attaques islamistes
il y à une période où j'étais elle a
déjà su à l'époque où on traiter et on
surveillait les filières liées à al
qaïda à l'époque avec avec surtout en
europe avec la suède ans à londres a
bien connu c'était le long de l'histoire
à cette période il y a eu après le 11
septembre
enfin le 11 septembre a déclenché enfin
à prouver que des groupes de terroristes
islamistes comme al qaïda était capable
de préparer et de commettre des
attentats de grande envergure dans un
état occidental et ensuite on a eu
plusieurs attentats je pense à l'espagne
l'année suivante je pense évidemment en
france où il faut avoir des moyens
financiers des moyens humains et
logistiques considérables pouvoir
préparer se déplacer et commettre les
attentats et la chose assez simple chez
eux c'est que ils n'ont pas besoin de
repartir
donc c'est déjà une grande partie du
travail qui est qu'ils accomplissent
c'est-à-dire s'infiltrer commettre
l'attentât
ce et ceux et combattre contre les
forces d'intervention
aujourd'hui la menace a changé la menace
est présente
au quotidien déjà il faut pas parler de
terrorisme sans parler de l'idéologie
qui est présente en europe de plus en
plus présente en europe depuis 2001 qui
a démarré selon moi depuis 1928 avec la
création des frères musulmans est là et
leur doctrine qui s'est répandue et qui
a été utilisé pour de nombreux groupes
islamistes
aujourd'hui monter un attentat de grande
envergure type 11 septembre ou type 13
13 novembre en france est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que tous les services de
renseignement occidentaux européens et
français
les français se sont adaptés ont déployé
de nombreux moyens de surveillance des
infiltrations d comment dirais-je des
des sources aussi de façon à anticiper
ces gros attentats en revanche les
attentats qui peuvent être commis par
des personnes qui se sont qui adhèrent
au projet islamiste qui décident de
passer à l'action à leur propre
initiative avec un camion c'est vous
avez dans votre dos vous dans votre
sujet vous avez fait référence à la au
triste anniversaire de l'attentât
islamiste à nice donc aujourd'hui
n'importe qui qui va déroger cela fait
forcément des groupuscules et des
organisations organisés sont plus des
personnes individuelles qui agissent
maintenant doudou là
difficulté la complexité évidemment on a
bien compris
pierre martinet mais messieurs
j'aimerais revenir sur la ministre des
armées florence parly qui s'est exprimé
tout à l'heure je cite il y aura une
place majeure de takouba dans les
prochains mois et prochaines années dans
le cadre de la transformation de
l'opération barkan takouba n'a pas
vocation à se battre à la place des
maliens si le contingent est moindre au
sel n'y at-il pas un risque que les
terroristes viennent plus facilement en
europe
cette question elle est pour vous
monsieur cissé mais juste avoir regardé
quand même cette infographie 2
de florence parler nous ne quittons pas
le sahel nour et adaptons notre
dispositif nous le transformons de façon
profonde
nous avons rencontré des succès dans le
combat que nous menons contre les
groupes terroristes comme ça mouille et
si c'est le fait que le contingent soit
donc moindre au mali et plus
généralement au sahel est ce que ça ne
peut pas créer bien des brèches pour
l'europe ensuite et fait des attentats
soient commis sur un vieux continent
alors ce que je voudrais dire par là il
est temps que les africains aussi
assument leurs propres figures ne pas
surtraiter sa défense et sa sécurité
bien entendu il y en a trop dit de
france et tous les pays
dorseuil unis contre le terrorisme
il est temps que les états du sahel
s'assume moins tendu parlementaire si un
petit peu dans les bois c'est
véritablement oui vous savez pas que
pour l'ensemble des moyens mais ça fait
huit ans de présence de forces
étrangères sur le sol malien
il est en amont a donné que les arbitres
en puissance pour l'instant l'avocat
récusant ainsi fi sens ça il faut le
reconnaître
et si taguba si la mission par cannes
prenait fin en décembre 2008 2022
enfin il 20h22 j'espère que cela nous
mettra du temps aux armées du sahel de
monter en puissance
je suis heureux de partager ce plateau
avec monsieur martinez qui est un
spécialiste de la question et quelques
voix près d'accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire en tous les cas il ya eu
des petites cliniques la tête de pierre
martinez tant que professeur en partie
d'accord
france 2 et de la sécurité je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec les queues et une
insuffisance mais moi nous relevant tant
qu malien il est temps qu'on sort de de
cette histoire de toujours demander à la
brigade nationale d'être à nous tuer
parce que temps pour ça je le dis
clairement je suis d'accord avec un
monsieur martin r mais ça fait huit ans
de présence de forces étrangères sur le
lien pour quel résultat pour quel
résultat c'est la question que tout
reste possible
donc à un moment donné est-ce que les
items la formation qui est dispensée par
le 8e et d'autres contingents et l'étang
de dévaluer et celle à six et à partir
de là nous allons comprendre enfin où
est ce que nous en sommes nous aussi
moi je pense qu'il faille à un moment
donné se mettent autour de la table et
discuter même avec les plus grands avec
les ehpad hantise parce que au mali ce
n'est pas du terrorisme en réalité c'est
plutôt il ya beaucoup de l'argot
trafiquants ya beaucoup de grandes
antilles je vais donc le 10 à 10 ans en
parlant de diakiss gueule vous il ya
pourtant al qaïda au maghreb islamique
et d'autres groupuscules comme celle a
bien marché je vous laisse choisir aux
propos de bénéfices et non vous avez les
noms et non al qaïda une autre quand on
en rajoute l'islam d'arrière voilà ce
sont des propos pour moi que je viens
vous dire en tout cas au centre et au
nord on a essentiellement des
narcotrafiquants et on voit ce qui était
d'abord de la rébellion pour
l'indépendance de l'azawad aujourd'hui
sont avec nous et au parlement de la
transition
beaucoup sont devenus ministres ils
reconnaissent leur moyenne t aujourd'hui
que les maliens sont en passe de se
réunir 12 juin six mois sur le dialogue
même avec les irrédentistes pierre
martinet alors je suis en partie
d'accord est ce que parce que monsieur
vient me dire c'est je suis absolument
d'accord avec lui quand il dit qu'il
faut absolument
pardonnez moi l'expression mais je vais
l'image et ils soient absolument enlever
la béquille de l'europe et de l'occident
de la france je suis absolument d'accord
avec vous permets moi dans mes
propositions dans les propositions que
je fais dans la différence d'état
africains parce que je travaille
essentiellement avec l'afrique c'est il
ya un ministre africain qui m'a dit
merci parce que vous allez nous aider à
ne plus être aidées il est impératif de
faire de la formation par des sociétés
autres que des états je fais pas de la
publicité je ne fais pas de la publicité
mais de façon à former les formateurs et
en dix ans
le lieutenant-colonel françois qui a
commandé la task force tu as comme allié
de janvier à avril 1 il a dit il faut ce
qu'on se concentrer sur la construction
de l'ami plutôt que la destruction de
l'ennemi
c'est peut-être ça ce que vous voulez
dire mais est-ce que c'est suffisant 50
50 on brasse et 50 % vrai les 50% il
faut il faut faire les deux même et moi
je suis je suis convaincu que que là que
les armées africaines que ce soit au
mali ou ailleurs parce que j'ai été dans
d'autres pays ont les moyens et les
capacités à se débrouiller seul il y
aura un temps d'adaptation mais moi je
pense qu'il faut changer le
considérablement dès maintenant ce
logiciel là c'est à dire ne pas attendre
de la de la coopération mais d'avoir une
collaboration et avoir de la formation
de formats stage de formation de
formateurs et ensuite d'être autonome
le but le but de takouba notamment je me
permets de vous couper parce qu'on a un
sujet à passer et vous allez parler
après pierre martinet puisque messieurs
on sait que la lutte contre le
terrorisme
elle passe par le combat sur le terrain
contre les groupes djihadistes au sahel
il ya d'ailleurs eu en ladhuie tout à
l'heure lors du défilé militaire sur les
champs-elysées un contingent de 73
membres de la task force de coups bas
qui opère donc au sel et qui regroupe
une nation pourtant emmanuel macron a
annoncé la fin de l'opération barque à
naucelle pour le début de l'année
prochaine
on a parlé il ya quelques instants alors
comment lutter contre le terrorisme sur
le terrain à la source avec l armée
éléments de réponse avec clément
delcourt hélène masquelier guillemard
aussi à gagner l'avenir c'était le thème
de cette édition 2021 de la parade
militaire du 14 juillet un avenir qui
s'annonce plus sombre et qui devrait
renouer avec les conflits de haute
intensité
c'est en tout cas l'hypothèse
privilégiée en haut lieu
nous sommes confrontés à une situation
où la pluralité des conflits possibles
est extrême mais surtout leur degré
d'intensité
c'est à juste titre nos armées se
prépare à des scénarios de combat de
très haute intensité durable 27
septembre 2020 la guerre éclate entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan dans le
haut-karabagh une guerre éclair et
meurtrière plus de 5000 morts en 44
jours mais surtout un conflit
conventionnel qui voit s'affronter deux
armées employant tout l'attirail
militaire avions de combat artillerie
système de défense anti-aérien
brouillage électronique drones forces
spéciales ou propagande sur les réseaux
sociaux
un avertissement pour certains
observateurs qui voient un retour aux
guerres de grande ampleur pour bientôt
au moment où arménien et azéri en
décousaient un haut gradé militaire
français thierry burkhard chef d'état
major de l'armée de terre tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé
demain les affrontements seront encore
plus durs et à une autre échelle avec
une autre intensité on a changé
en fait le monde a changé la
conflictuelle it et est en train de
changer
la guerre la france y est habituée elle
qui déploie ses soldats sur de nombreux
terrains d'opérations extérieures les
fameuses opex depuis des décennies
afghanistan syrie libye sahel mais ces
derniers conflits sont dits asymétrique
et ne sont pas comparables aux guerres
annoncée pour demain
cela fait plus de dix ans que l'armée
s'est concentrée sur la menace du moment
qui était le terrorisme melita risée en
prévision de ces nouveaux conflits
la france ça remet de nouveau son budget
augmente de 1,7 milliard d'euros chaque
année depuis 2018 et devrait atteindre
44 milliards en 2023 soit plus de 25 %
de hausse en cinq ans pour autant cela
ne suffit pas du moins si l'on en croit
celui qui est encore chef d'état-major
des armées jusqu au 21 juillet la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle
aujourd'hui ne vise pas une montée en
puissance ou l'acquisition d'une masse
qui permettrait à l'armée de s'engager
dans un conflit étatique majeur deux
généraux mais un même constat
et ce n'est pas un hasard si le général
thierry burkhard un homme de terrain qui
a servi en irak et dans l'ex yougoslavie
a été récemment désigné pour remplacer
d'ici à une semaine
le général françois lecointre avec pour
objectif la préparation de la défense
française à des conflits d'ampleur et de
nature différente et la fin de
l'opération barkan au sahel qui
permettra le rapatriement de 3000
soldats français s'inscrit clairement
dans cet objectif
pierre martinet d'un côté on augmente le
budget dans notre côté on l'a dit on se
désengage du sahel difficile de
comprendre là la stratégie la ligne
directrice tout ça pour le rappel lutter
contre contre le terrorisme c'est le
postulat de départ de ce décryptage
alors c'est compliqué de lui moi j'ai vu
je vais vous résumer la situation
ouverte qui paraît-il et viennent des
talibans l'occident à la montre et nous
avons le temps donc effectivement on
s'engage sur des opérations pour stopper
un califat donc on va dire qu'on s'est
engagé au mali pour stopper en italie
faire puisque nous parlons du mali je
suis avec mon ami malien et on s'engage
pour le stopper militairement le stop
parce que l'occident ait les moyens
matériels humains militaire de stopper
un califat comment dirais-je qui n'est
pas une armée conventionnelle qui est
plutôt des groupes de guérilla on va
dire merde comme on fait quoi on y reste
dix ans quinze ans c'est impossible en
fait comment comment voulez vous que la
population présente puisse accepter une
armée étrangère même si au départ allait
voter pour pour aider puisse accepter
une armée étrangère 10 15 ans 20 ans
plus tard sur le territoire il ya un an
donc maintenant comme vous dites c'est
enlever la béquille pour pouvoir aider
l'armée malienne bam sommes brouillés si
c'est maintenant que
barkan s'en va takouba est là qu est ce
qui va se passer concrètement concret
doit se passer
excusez moi concrètement ce qui doit se
passer c'est qu'effectivement il va y
avoir des forces spéciales qui vont
ponctuellement et éliminer des poches de
terroristes islamistes
mais il est il est plus urgent que nos
amis africains que nos frères africains
prennent leur destin en main et ils ont
la capacité humaine technique
psychologique ils ont toutes les
capacités jeu pour avoir formé des
armées africaines je sais qu'ils sont
plus autant capable commis que le faire
de le faire il n'y a pas de problème
martinez je laisse ban se mouiller si
c'est parler puisqu'il a un peu moins
parler vous un témoin alors
effectivement ce que dit pierre martinet
et utah sucre un moment donné il faut
comprendre nous mais la béquille il faut
l'enlever faut l'enlever du dirigeant à
dose homéopathique et non pas mais c'est
mieux pratiquer la le fait de se retirer
complètement début d'avis 2022 où j'en
avais des alertes je pense quand même on
aider à les relier au mois de juin une
décision du président macro qui avait
décidé d'arrêter de disparition
conjointe l'armée malienne
donc je pense qu'il est témoin de vous
couper est-ce que c'est pas entre
guillemets une sanction par rapport à
tout ce qui s'est passé au mali
récemment entre le coup d'état
d'août dernier on a parlé d'un deuxième
coup d'état ensuite avec meego ita il ya
eu la cedeao ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont passés au mali c'est difficile à
comprendre
sk pas derrière la france qui a dit bon
on se retire parce que là ça devient
trop compliqué alors moi ce que tu pas
être trop alarmiste ou alarmant mais je
m'explique le sahel et jean jean pierre
martinez peu le confirme ici le ciel
tombe à cause du terrorisme parce qu'il
ya quand même
il est le titre au risque malgré tout
pas forcément pour moi les toxines et
said tombe
si vous aussi de tonnes s'il sera encore
plus proche des ports de laurent lopez
extérieur s'il n'est pas anodin la
france n'est pas là que pour idée nous
est c'est aussi pour se préserver éviter
justement que ce terrorisme militarisé
vrai plan de rigueur sur son sol et
notamment sur l'ensemble de l'europe
dont doit être sûr c'est que je dis qu
il faut faire attention de vouloir se
retirer à tout prix ou de mettre la
pression parce que guerrier de coup
d'état oat coup de force des militaires
vous savez souvent les pays comme la
france je suis d'accord c'est sans
détails démocratie faut qu'ils
comprennent que nous avons 60 ans
d'indépendance nous avons pas descendre
de deux les 200 ans du république et moi
souvent je le dis je ne suis pas à la
date des coups d'état mais perd martinez
est un témoin privilégié pour dire que
la gabégie ou de paris destinée à autre
chose son la pose de ses coudes et dana
tant qu' il ya une nouvelle gouvernance
on aura des coups d'état donc où les
deux condamnés ou de mettre la pression
pour les coups d'état on devrait d'abord
condamné ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont
censés être représentatifs de la
population une qui ont en main les
destinées du pays et qu'il faut du grand
n'importe quoi à terme de gestion
financière en termes de gabegie et de
vol d'escroquerie toujours si l'élite
dans ces pays la suite sur le podium
s'il vous plaît si vous permettez
illustré rapidement de ce canadien
prétend voilà le propos de monsieur
passons devant le clan des mollets
macron moi je rechute et qui lui
tiennent sur le sol africain
parce que moi je les interprète tu
l'analyse comme s'il était parti
chercher un petit peu la protection du
maquereau mois qu'on ne le protégera pas
c'est à lui de travailler dans son pays
sinon on peut aussi ne sera pas à l'abri
d'un coup d'état ça c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui vous avez une policière à
100 kg et là vous avez dit militaire
si martin est le type qui s'assume et
des militaires maliens nigériens
tchadiens qui s'assume et qui à mon
atelier
merci merci c'est la fin de ce
décryptage merci bones mouillé si c'est
d'avoir et prendre une question vous
êtes parlementaires maliens et membre du
conseil de la transition à bamako merci
également à vous car martinez ex agent
de la dgse et fondateur de whincup
security défense reste